welcome to this two hour introduction to
modern react we're gonna take you all
the way from learning how to deploy your
first react app
to building components to managing state
and finally into frameworks like next js
this originally appeared as a 15-part
series
on my channel the blue collar coder and
if you're interested in more videos like
this
be sure to check that link out and
that's in the description but in the
meantime of course
let's get right into it welcome to
episode one
of the blue collar coder introduction to
react series
i'm jack harrington add to her on
twitter i'm
really excited you're here and i'm happy
to help you
skill up on react so
a couple of things before we get started
first react is built on top of html
js and css so if you're feeling like
you're not
completely fluent in any of those you're
probably going to want to use some of
the description
links down in the description to kind of
skill up on that before
you jump into this course for example on
the html side you want to know about
tags like div input button table
on the css side we're going to do some
text formatting as well as some grid
layout and then on the js side
object arrays functions all of these
things you're going to want to have a
pretty decent grasp of
before you get into react now in the
second note
blue collar coder is all about practical
use of skills so this is gonna be a
practical course i'm not gonna go and
dig into every nook and cranny
in the react ecosystem there is a lot
out there
but i can guarantee you that by the end
of this you'll be able to create
really cool react apps for yourself
and be able to work on a team of with
other react developers
and then third in kind of true blue
color code or fashion we're going to
start a little bit in reverse
we're going to do deployment first in
this video you're going to learn how to
create
and deploy your own react app and why
are we doing that first well i want you
to understand
how react apps are structured in their
use of html js and css
and deployed to a web server and
secondly i just think it's really cool
you can go and deploy your app to github
pages
for free and have it used by anybody in
the world i just think that's really
neat and i want you to be able to go and
show all the cool stuff that you're
learning to your friends your family
your coworkers and whomever you want
all right without further ado let's go
jump into building
your first react app and let's get at it
so to create our first react app we're
going to look at the
create a new react app page on the react
site and we're going to scroll down to
create react app
which is a handy little helper
application that'll makes it easy to
create
react apps and now to use that
we use mpx now if you don't have node
installed
you probably don't have mpx so in order
to get node installed
you want to have a look at nvm or the
node version manager there's a link to
that in the description
and you can use the os specific
installation instructions down in
installing and updating
to install a recent version of node i'd
suggest
something like node 12 into your system
now let's say that we have mpx installed
let's go follow this so we're going to
use mpx create react app
and then i'm going to use starting react
as the name
and that takes a little while to
complete i've sped it up here for you
and then i'll cd into starting react
and do code dot which brings up vs code
in that directory
and then from there i'll bring up the
terminal
and i can do yarn start to start the
application
and if everything's worked fine you'll
see this really nice
spinning react logo next to your code so
now in the next few videos we're
obviously going to drill down into that
and see how that works
but right now we're just going to deploy
it
so we'll stop that and we'll go over and
take a look at the instructions
that are in the create react
documentation
for deployments i'm going to search for
deploy
go to the deployment page and there's a
link to that in the description
if you just want to get there the easy
way
and i'll scroll down to github pages
because that's what we're going to use
for our deploy
and the first step with that is to have
a github repo
so let's go over to github
now if you don't have an account you're
going to want to create one i already
have one
and i'm going to jump into my
repositories tab
and then select a new repository
and put in the same name starting react
i'll just copy and paste it in there and
then i'll create a simple description
doesn't really matter
it's optional and then create the
repository
now handily for us create react app has
actually done
most of the work here for us it's done
the get in it the add the commit
the branch and now we
have to do these final two commands so
first we'll do the get remote ad
now the remote add has connected
the repository in this directory to the
repository on github
now in order to get the code over there
we've got to follow the next command
which
pushes the code from this directory into
github
and now if i refresh i can see that the
code's been uploaded i can even click on
view code
and it looks exactly the same as what's
over in my directory
on vs code so let's go back to the
deployment page again
and the first thing we want to do is
change package.json to add this homepage
key
now you just paste it in there
and i'm going to change out my username
for jahr which is my username
and change out my app for starting react
which is the name of the project
now scroll down a little bit more and
we'll see step two is to install gh
pages
so i use yarn but if you use npm that's
fine i'm gonna do yarn add gh pages
and then in order to use that we got to
go add some more scripts
to the package json so i'll copy in the
script commands
from the documentation into the scripts
in package.json starting with pre-deploy
and then deploy and now i'm going to run
pre-deploy to go and build what's
actually going to go onto github
and that's going to create this build
directory so let's go have a look at
that
on osx i can use the open command to
just open up that directory
in the finder
and we can see at the top we've got
index.html that's the really important
part that's the html page
that is going to be presented in github
pages there's a lot of other little
things around here logos and whatnot and
then the next most important part is the
static directory let's have a look at
that
and that's got css js and media css
is whatever css we had in the
application
js is the web packed source code
for our react application and media is
the
react logo as an svg what's really
important about all this
is you understand that a react app
is still just html css
js and images and any other kind of
media that you've got
all of these frameworks angular view
react they all compile to javascript
and the magic happens when that
javascript is executed
on the page and starts filling in the
html tags
so let's close this up and now i'm going
to deploy the app
so all i have to do is just type in yarn
deploy
and that's the really great part anytime
you want to go and show your work you
just do yarn deploy
and it's going to send it to github
so once that's complete i can go over
into this branches drop down and we see
we have a master
and we also have gh pages and that's for
github pages and that was created by
that yarn deploy command and the gh
pages library
so now i'm going to go into settings if
you scroll down to github pages
there's a link right there that you can
click on
and see the deployed app
really nice and it looks exactly like
what's on my local machine
but now anybody in the world can look at
that app just by bringing up that url on
their phone
or their laptop
so then i'm going to start it locally
again so you can play around a little
bit
so now that we have the inspector open i
can go and click on preferences
scroll down to disable javascript and
then just
refresh the page
and you'll see that it's warning you
that you need to enable javascript to
run this app
and that's because the body of the
document if we look over
here to the left just has
a noscript tag and this div
for root but we know that there's a lot
more going on in there so what's
happening is that the javascript that's
listed down below is actually going to
populate the contents of that
root tag and that's how a react app
works
when it's what we call client-side
rendered which means that all of the
rendering of the application is done
on the client side all right now if i
re-enable javascript we can see that it
works again
that's great and we can see if we look
into the
elements portion of the chrome inspector
that we now have all these tags
inside of that root text we've got a div
with class equals app we've got a header
paragraph tags got a whole bunch of
stuff in there and that's created by
that javascript
that is running the react library that
then
renders out our application
okay well i hope you've got a react app
up on github pages
next thing to do is to learn how to
manage the html how to use what's called
the jsx
syntax inside of your react app so
that's what the next video is going to
be on
welcome to episode 2 of the blue collar
coder
introduction to react series i'm jack
harrington at jahr on twitter
so in this one we're going to learn how
to build out your html
in a react app using what's called jsx
and the little gotchas
that make it not too tough but you know
you got to look out for those sort of
things
so without further ado let's go jump
into the code
so to figure out how to make html in our
react app
we're going to go and edit the app.js
component so let's open up app.js
so the first thing that i do after
creating a react app is to
take out a lot of stuff i'm going to go
and take out
almost all of this html and take it down
to just one div
as we can see we no longer need the logo
so we can remove that so we'll just have
at this point the css
that we would use in the page and this
div
now to create our pokemon search app
we're going to start with creating an h1
so i'm just going to put an h1 in here
and say pokemon search
now we'll start the app
and we can see that now we have a blank
page
with pokemon search in there and it's
nice and big and bold because it's nh1
and if we go over to the css we can then
remove all the css that's there
and let's define a new class and call it
title
and we'll just say that we wanted text
align center
and we'll head back over into the js
and then say that the class name is
title
and this is something that trips people
up when they're first learning react
is that you don't say class in react you
say class
name and that's because of how
jsx which is this extension to
javascript that allows us to put
html tags into our source code manages
or converts this jsx code into
javascript
in javascript you can't say
the class of an element you can't do
class you have to say
class name and so that's why you have to
say class name in this context
is that this is actually being converted
to javascript for you
and in javascript you gotta say class
name in order to specify
the class another gotcha is
around styling so in html we're used to
defining
styles as a property right
quote and then some properties with
dashes in it
it's different in react so in react
you use an object and you do that by
opening up curly braces and that
escapes you back into javascript and
then you create
an object so you create another set of
curly braces so you end up with
nested curly braces in this case i'm
going to say that the margin
is auto and that's going to put the
entire contents
of this page kind of into the center of
the page
i'm going to say that the width of the
page is 800 pixels
and now i could do that as a string like
i'm doing that here
but in react it's more common to use
just an integer value
when react sees an integer value for
property
a style property it translates that into
pixels
and then finally i'm going to say that
we want some padding on the top
of one rim
now you can't really use dashes when
you're doing an object
in javascript you can but it's it's not
as easy
you have to put quotes around it so
instead in react
we camel case css properties
that have dashes in them so in this case
it's
padding capital t top
and so you can see that that's moved it
down a little bit
now in our application we're going to
search for pokemon and we're going to
create a table of that so let's go
and create a table we'll set it with 100
add a tr add a td
and now we right click on that page and
we go into the inspector
we actually get a warning and that
warning is telling us that
the table isn't properly specified
and you might be like what that looks
like a good table to me well it actually
turns out that it's not
quite perfect html what it's saying is
that we need a
t-body tag and that's going to be the
body of the table
so let's add that in there
and we'll just wrap that row in that t
body
and then we'll create another tag called
t head and that will have
the header section
and just copy and paste in the existing
row
change out our tds and convert them to
th's
in this case i'm using the extend
selection command
in vs code you grab the first td
and then on mac you do command d
three more times and that extends the
selection to all of the
tds in this row and then you just type
in
your replacement value so in this case
th and it's very easy
to make kind of bulk changes that way so
now let's change out the header
to name and type
and that looks really nice and we can go
back into our css
and say that we want all of our headers
aligned on the left
and a little bit larger and that works
just fine
just save and immediately receive the
results
all right well as you can see react
makes it pretty easy
to just kind of copy and paste in your
html code
and then fix up things like class and
class name and then the styles but
otherwise
it's pretty amenable to making whatever
kind of html you want
welcome to episode three of the blue
collar coder introduction to react
series i'm jack harrington
at jahr on twitter so iterating over
lists
is something we need to do in almost any
web application
and react is no different so in this one
we're going to bring in
a whole list of pokemon and show you how
to build a big table out of that
it's pretty fun let's go jump into the
code so the next thing we're going to do
is bring in our pokemon so down in the
description
there is a link to the pokemon.json file
which is a github gist
i'm going to open that up and then click
on the raw button to get the raw file
in my browser which has a json extension
it looks like this but you know
it'll look fairly similar to this and
i'm just going to select all of that
and create a new file called pokemon
json and just paste it in
and i'll use a command in vs code format
document
and that'll make it look nice
so let's scroll all the way up to the
top of the file and we can see that this
is an array it's a big array of objects
each object is a pokemon it has an id
those ids conveniently start with one
there is the name which is specified in
english japanese
chinese and french there is the type
which is an array of the different types
of a pokemon
and then there is a structure called
base which has
essentially the game mechanics
of a pokemon so it's hit points his
attack defense special attack special
defense
and speed it's a nice piece of data to
play around with
now to get this into our app it's
actually pretty easy
we're just going to import it we're
going to say import pokemon
from pokemon json
how's that and now we've got this
pokemon array so how do we go and
format that into our html document well
the first thing you need to do is open
up curly braces
and then we're going to say pokemon.map
and what that's going to do is run the
map method
against that pokemon array and map
takes a function that function then
takes
two different parameters in this case it
takes pokemon and an index but we'll
just use the pokemon
and you get to specify what the return
is for every pokemon
so in this case we're going to open up
parentheses again
and grab that tr row and paste it
into that map
you see this all the time in react
applications and as soon as i hit save
you can see that now we've got a whole
bunch of rows
all of which say exactly the same thing
balasar and
grass poison so now let's change out
bulbasaur
for curly braces pokemon name
english
alright so going back to that pokemon
json file
we know that there is a name structure
and within that as english
so pokemon.name.english now over in
the next row we're going to say
pokemon.type
but it's an array so how are we going to
format it so that it looks good
well there is an array function called
join
so let's use that
and then give it the string of a comma
with a space after it and that's going
to give us a nice comma separated string
with all of the values
in that array hit save again
and wow that's really nice look at that
now you've got all the pokemon
and it's got their names but let's go
over and look at the inspector again
and we can see that in the console we're
getting some complaints and what it's
complaining about is the fact that we're
iterating over something we're creating
a whole bunch of new tags but we're not
giving them a key value and that key
value is
really important to react because it's
how it manages
all of the tags that are created as you
iterate
over a list it wants to be able to
efficiently identify
that this particular html element is
bound to this particular piece of data
so that should that data not change it
won't go and update
the cell which is really nice for
performance
so we're going to add in key and then we
need to give it something unique
so in this case we already have
something which is the id
so we'll just put in pokemon id
and that's perfectly fine and valid but
if you don't have something like that
let's just say that
you know an id didn't exist what you can
do is you can go and join a couple of
values together so for example we could
use the id
and the name in english and use that
join method
to join them with a semicolon or a colon
and that would give you a unique id so
you can synthesize
your own unique ids the important part
here is that
the key needs to be unique amongst all
its siblings doesn't have to be unique
for the whole page it just needs to be
unique amongst all its siblings
so we'll just use pokemon.e since it's
exactly that
and we'll go back into the console
and voila it works but that's a really
long list there's a lot of pokemon as it
turns out so you can also use
other array methods like in this case
dot slice to pare that down so i'm going
to say that we only want
the first 20.
so we'll start with index 0 and slice
off
20 items and then we'll map those and
the nice
thing here is that since dot slice
returns an array we can just kind of
stack these things up so
pokemon.slice.map and you see that a lot
all right welcome to episode four of the
blue color coder
introduction to react series i'm jack
harrington at jahr on twitter and in
this one we're gonna do what react does
best which is make
your own components it's really cool
it's pretty much why we use react the
ability to create components and then
reuse them
it's just really cool stuff so without
further ado let's go
and augment our pokemon app by creating
our own components
react is all about components and in
this case the app component
is getting pretty big so let's go and
create ourselves a
new component we'll call it pokemon row
and a component is easily defined using
a function and the first argument of
that function
is the properties of the component
so you get to define the properties that
you want for your component
in this case i'm going to say that the
property is pokemon
and i'm just going to paste in the
existing row that we had down there
now to use this all i need to do is
change out that tr
to be the pokemon row
and then remove the additional items
i'm also going to remove the key from
the component
because we don't need it over there
and here's the problem so we've
specified the key but we haven't
given a value for that pokemon property
that we said that we wanted
so we need to add in pokemon
and then give it the value of that
pokemon
that really nice look at that how easy
is that
but there's something more that we can
do to specify
a component we can use what are called
prop types
so what you need to do is do yarn add
prop dash types it's a library
and that prop types library gives you a
set of
property types you can then identify
each property
of your component using those types so
let's import that
and to use that we're going to do
pokemonrow.prop types
and then an object and each key in that
object is going to be whatever your
properties are so in this case we take a
pokemon
and we'll say that it's going to be a
string
now i know it's not a string but i just
want to show you over in the browser
what it looks like when you pass
something that
isn't the right prop type so we're going
to pass an object a pokemon object
but we've said that it's supposed to be
a string and so we get is this warning
that says
invalid prop pokemon of type object
supplied to pokemon row but we've
expected a string
isn't that nice so let's fix that and to
do that we're going to specify a
shape that's how you specify an object
in
prop types language
and so the relevant parts to us would be
the type in this case which is an array
of
strings so we say prop types dot array
of and then give it
the prop types string
and that's looking good but we also want
to say that we have a shape which is the
name
and we're looking for english in there
so this is basically the minimum
set of properties that are required
for this component okay so we're passing
more
but that's fine as long as what you've
specified
is there you're good to go
so i gotta say this is how i fell in
love with react
the first time that i started working
with it is by creating my own components
and sharing them with other people i
thought that was great so
i really hope that you get excited by
this and go and make
your own components share them with your
team or share them on open source
whatever you want to do with it welcome
to episode 5
of the blue collar coder introduction to
react series
i hope you're enjoying it as much as i
enjoy making it
so in this one we're going to learn how
about how to use react hooks
to store state and also listen for
events it's going to take your react app
and make it dynamic
which is really cool but it can be a bit
overwhelming to learn that all in one
video i tried to figure out how to break
it into multiple videos but i gotta say
it
you know it was better suited for just
just one
so if you feel overwhelmed be sure just
to watch the video again and
and get comfortable with it alright
without further ado
let's go jump into state management and
events
so now we're going to allow the user to
be able to search
for the pokemon that they want so the
first thing to do is go and add an input
tag
then we're going to go over to the css
and format it
make it with 100 percent
make the font size larger give it a
little padding and to make it look nice
and we want to track the value of
that input so we need state so we're
going to use
what's called a react hook and to do
that
we're going to use react.ustate
and usestate returns an array
it has two items in it in this case the
first one is the current state
we'll call filter and the second is a
function
called filter set which sets that filter
and then we'll go down to our input and
we'll say that the value
is filter and then
we'll handle an event so in react
you handle events by saying on and then
the event name so in this case
on change
because change is called whenever a
input field changes
and then we give it an anonymous
function in this case that anonymous
function takes an event
and we're going to use filter set to set
the value of the filter
to the target value coming in from that
event
now in order to use that filter we're
going to add on
another method onto our table
array iterator and that's dot filter
dot filter allows us to apply a filter
to an array
and it returns the array where only the
array elements that match the criteria
specified in the function that's given
come back in the array so in this case
we're going to be given a pokemon
and we're going to say that if the
name.english
includes the value of filter we're going
to
show that we're going to allow that to
pass that filter
so i go over to the browser and then i
type in bulb in this case
it narrows it down to just bulbasaur
now there's a little bit of trick here
it's going to be case sensitive
because includes this case sensitive so
i'm going to use
two lower case to change english to
lower case
and then do the same for filter
and that's going to make it a case
insensitive search
so now we want to extend our application
a little bit
we want to be able to have the user
select a pokemon
and then get more information about it
so let's go and wrap
the table in a div
and then in that div we're going to use
a grid layout so we're going to say
display grid
and we're going to specify that the
columns the grid template columns
are 70 and 30 percent
give it a nice layout
there's a little gap between them of one
rim
and then we're going to go take that
table and the input and we're going to
drop it into the first div
and now we need some more state because
we're going to allow the customer to
select
a pokemon so we're going to create
another react use state
called selected item
and then down below the div that
includes the input field
and the table we're going to add another
div
that's going to be shown if we have a
selected item and the way that you do
that is that you use a syntax where you
say open curly braces
and then you give it your conditional as
well as
ampersand ampersand and then the
html code that you want to display
so in this case the conditional is if
there is a selected item
so just select an item an ampersand
ampersand and then we'll go and add some
html code
and we'll just say that we want to show
the selected items name
in an h1 so how do we have the user
select
a pokemon so we're going to add a new
custom
event to our pokemon row component and
it's
going to be called on select
we'll even add it to the prop types
we'll say that on select is a function
that's a prop type stop func and we're
going to add a third column
with a button that button's going to say
select
and the on click handler for that
is going to call our on select and then
give it back the pokemon
that it was given
now if i save at this point we get an
error because on select is not a
function
we haven't actually given it an on
select
down in our array iterator so let's go
do that
so go and add in here on select
and then give it a function that
function is going to take a pokemon
because that's what we've specified as
what's going to come out of our custom
event
and then we're going to use that with
the selected item set
use state function and give it the
pokemon
now we can go over to the page and we
can click on any of these and we're
selecting
the pokemon really cool right
so let's make this even a little better
let's go and give us
some more information about that pokemon
so we're going to create
another component and call it pokemon
info
it's going to take the name of the
pokemon as well as this base structure
and
that's all that information about the
combat strengths of a pokemon
and it's going to do the h1 at the top
with the name in english
and so to use our new component we're
going to invoke that just the same way
that we did pokemon row
but and do a little bit differently
we're going to go and say that we want
to send along all of the attributes of
the selected item now
you'd think that we could just put in
there selected item like that but that's
not quite right what we need to do we
need to spread
all of the properties of selected item
into properties that are then mapped
onto pokemon info
and to do that we just open curly braces
and then
use the spread operator which is the
ellipses dot dot
and selected item
so in that case every key that's in
selected item
is mapped to a property that goes to
pokemon info
that's why name now goes across and it
works just fine
and now base is in there but we're not
using it yet so let's go and define our
prop types
so first we have that name it's a shape
property that has english on it
so i'm just going to bring in some code
that does exactly the same thing for
base
and now notice that i've also added this
is required
so for example hp is a required number
so you've got prop
types.number dot is required and we can
pretty much use that wherever we want
to in this because everything is going
to be required
all right we're still looking good so
the last thing we want to do
is show all of the base
values we want to show the combat
strengths of this particular pokemon so
create another table yeah put pokemon
info
and we're gonna do another iterator but
in this case
we're going to use object.keys on base
now object.keys takes an object and
returns an array
of all of the key values so in this case
it's going to be things like
attack hp all of that stuff
and then we're going to use that same
map function
to take that key and then return a row
where the key is the key name of the key
and then we have tds
for both the key as well as the base
value
with that key
now when we click on select we get the
ivysaur
with hp of 60 attack of 62 and so on so
forth it's a nice
way of being able to iterate over an
object and show
all the keys and values that are in
there
okay well i hope you've learned
something new if it's overwhelming of
course feel free to rewatch the video
again i think that's free on youtube as
far as i know
welcome to episode six of the blue
collar coder introduction to react
series
i'm jack harrington at jahr on twitter
so one of the primary skills that you
need
as a web developer is to understand how
to do asynchronous work if you're going
to talk to a web service
it's going to be asynchronous so in this
one we're going to learn how to do just
that
so without further ado let's jump into
the code so
our requirements have changed and now we
have to load this pokemon file
not from a file but from a web service
so to imitate that we're going to go and
take the pokemon json file
and move it from source to public
and now we see immediately upon reload
that we've failed to compile
that file is now missing so let's go and
remove the import
so the first thing we need is a place to
put the data that we get after we load
it
so we'll go and create another use state
and we'll call a
value and value setter coming out of use
state
pokemon and pokemon set
and we'll just initialize that with an
empty array and that means that
the ui will always be alive there just
won't be anything to search on until we
get the data
so we can type in anything we want and
there's nothing to find
so we're going to use a new effect we're
going to use
react dot use effect
and what this does is it runs a function
in reaction to a change
so i'll specify the function first
and the second argument is an array of
values that when they change
you want that original function to run
so in this case for example if we wanted
to change on filter we could just type
in filter there
but if you leave it blank if you just
have an empty array what happens is
react use effect gets run once when the
component is first
put onto the page and then never run
again and that's what we're going to do
in this case because
we want to go get the data once
essentially on page load
and never get it again
so i'm just going to use a standard
fetch
and then let's go get the url for this
it's pokemon.json which is great on
localhost under starting react
so i'll just paste in localhost
and then type in the rest of the url
now fetch gives us a promise so we need
to call
dot then on it and the first thing it
gives us is a response
so we need to ask for the json response
on that so we'll give it a function
that takes just the json response
and then once you've got the json
response we can cascade that
then by creating another then
which has the data
and at this point all we need to do is
call pokemon set with that data
and there you have it so now we've got
the data the pokemon data being
dynamically loaded
onto the page if you want to see that
happen we'll go over to the inspector
and then click on network
then go to xhr
and refresh the page and you can see
pokemon.json being loaded
so that's one way of doing asynchronous
work
in react you could also do this on an on
click handler
if you wanted to load some data or make
some post calls in reaction to the user
actually
making a change or clicking a button all
right use effect hook it could probably
use
its own video digging into every nook
and cranny in fact i've
got that one on the list to do later on
so welcome
episode 7 of the blue collar coder
introduction to react series
i'm jack harrington on twitter so we've
learned
all kinds of stuff so far we've learned
about jsx we've learned how to handle
events we've learned how to do
asynchronous work we learned how to
store state
that's pretty much the main bucket of
information you need to know
to be a really good react coder but in
the real world
there's a couple of extra things that
you're going to need to know in almost
any app
and one of those is css in js up until
now we've been doing either
a style property on a tag or even hack
it on that css file
in the real world most applications use
some flavor of
css in javascript or css and js
this one we're going to use emotion so
without further ado
let's jump into learning emotion so the
the framework that we're going to use
for our css and js
is emotion which is a very popular css
and js
framework and the variant we want is
emotion
styled so i'm going to scroll down to
emotion styled
and this is the install command to
install it
so we'll go over to our vs code paste it
into the terminal and run it
and now let's restart again
okay looks good
so now i'm going to import styled
from emotion styled
let's see what do we want to do let's
start off with something simple let's
start off with the pokemon search title
so i'm going to define title
as style.h1
and then give it a template and in that
template is going to be the css
so go over to the app.css grab out the
css
and drop it in there and now we've
effectively got
this title tag it is it has an h1
but that h1 has the css so let's go use
that
and we'll replace the h1 with that title
nice and clean right and now we can
remove that title from the app css
so let's replace the two column layout
in this div with a two column layout tag
and this will show you how to convert
react style css back
into regular css
so again i'll create a constant
this time it's two column layout
a style div and then i'll just paste in
the react css and then i'll fix that up
by
removing any quotes changing the camel
case back to having dashes again
and adding semicolons where appropriate
now that we've got our two column layout
we can go use it by replacing that div
stuff just gets a bit more clean i gotta
say it looks much better
and let's see if it's actually working
by making some changes we'll change it
to 30 70.
yep looks bad but at least we can see
that the changes are made
so now let's change out the container
for the whole page
so i'll copy the style property values
and then create a container as a style
div
in this case with that 800 we actually
had to specify that we wanted that 800
pixels
so now let's go and change out that div
and that becomes a nice clean layout so
the last one i wanted to do is the input
so let's go and grab the input
definition from the app.css file
and then delete it
now create an input capital i input
and now i'll create a capital i input
as a styled input
paste in css
and we can use it just by replacing
lowercase input with uppercase input
by convention in react any component
should be uppercased
okay that was pretty fun so we've
learned how to use emotion
in our app and it looks a lot tidier
right
you gotta say it's pretty slick welcome
to the blue collar coder introduction to
react
episode eight i'm jack harrington at
jahr on twitter
wow we've learned a lot so
we don't generally speaking start from
brass tacks when it comes to you know
building out the the
look and feel of a page most of the time
we're gonna use
a component library so that's what we're
going to do in this video we're going to
use the material ui
component library and give ourselves a
nice look and feel
right out of the box so without further
ado
let's jump into the code there are a
bunch of different component libraries
for react this one we're looking at
right now is material ui it's very
popular
there's also shards one just came out
recently from adobe called spectrum
and that is just a very small sampling
for this we're going to use material ui
so here are the installation
instructions we just need to install
material ui core
i'm going to copy that and then i'm
personally going to use yarn add
in material ui core
and i'll start the server again
now the next thing on here was to go and
add this style sheet reference
so copy that
and then paste that into the index.html
in public
and it goes in the index.html because
that's the container
template html now there's a whole bunch
of components there's components that
cover everything but
for this we're just going to try out
button so i'm going to copy the import
line here
and then paste it into our code
and then i'm going to change the
lowercase b button that we had for
select and turn it into that uppercase b
button
use that component
and now we can see that we've got a
standard material button which in this
case has no boundaries so let's go take
a look at
some of the options on that
but it still works just like everything
else
so we'll go bring up the documentation
for components and button in particular
and that primary one looks pretty cool
so let's give that a try
so we'll copy the variant and the color
out
and paste those into our code
and that looks really nice
but it's not quite right in material ui
there is a baseline css
so let's go over to our index.js file
and then import from material ui core
so i'm just going to use the same import
as we had before but then change out
button for css baseline
and then i can put that into the
reactdom.render which
wraps our app our react app
and now you can see that the fonts have
changed a little bit and it's a little
bit
tighter and cleaner you gotta say that
looks nice
right out of the box right the button
just just it's just pretty and they've
got really good stuff in there for
layout and all kinds of stuff so
material ui is a really good library
i've used it in a lot of my videos i've
also used
the chars library i'll be probably doing
something with spectrum coming up pretty
soon
so there's just a lot of great stuff out
there it's a great time
to work in open source and use these
awesome utilities
welcome to episode 9 of the blue collar
coder
introduction to react series this is
actually the final episode of this
initial
run i'm jack harrington at jahr on
twitter
so react has had a long
history in the beginning with about 0.13
we had react.create class and that was
our way of creating components
and then we moved into the es6 class
syntax
and then obviously in the last couple
years we've gone with the functional
syntax that we've done
so far using functions to create
components
but if you're working on an older
application or in some circumstances you
actually need one of these
you need to know how to make a class
component or at least work on an
existing class component so in this one
we're going to take the app functional
component and convert it into a class
component you get to see how that's done
all right without further ado let's go
convert ourselves a function
so we're going to change our app
component from a function
based component to a class-based
component
so the first thing to do is to define
the class
and then we'll say that it extends react
component you have to have react
component as your base class
and then we'll create a constructor
and that constructor takes the
properties
and now the first thing you have to do
in this constructor is you always have
to call your superclass
and give it those properties
the other thing is required in a class
component
is a render method
the render method does not take any
arguments
so let's convert the state over so back
in the constructor i'm going to define
this dot state and that's an
object and i'm going to say that our
filter starts as an empty string
our pokemon starts as an empty array
and our selected item starts as null
and that's the functional equivalent of
these use states that we had in the
functional version of the component so
now let's grab our jsx
and paste that in as the return of the
render
so now we no longer have filter set
instead
we need to do this dot set state
and this dot set state takes an object
so we want to do is say that we want all
of the original object
by spreading this dot state and then
adding the filter key
with the new value
and that's the class equivalent of
filter set
now down here in the table we need to
change pokemon to this
dot state.pokemon
so everything coming into this component
whether it be properties which would be
this.props
or state which would be this dot state
is going to be on this
next thing to do is change the filter on
in the includes
then we need to update the on select to
again
set state
but this time we'll be setting selected
item
and now we gotta update the pokemon info
at the bottom with this.state
i think we're done with the basics here
so i'm just going to copy out the react
use effect
because we'll get to that in a second
and then remove the functional version
of the app component
and just paste that use effect into a
comment and see how we go
all right well filter is not defined so
let's go and see where we
messed up looks like i missed on the
input so let's add that
and that looks great so now we've got to
go get the data so where do we do that
well in a class component you actually
get a bunch of methods for the different
life cycle events and one of those
lifecycle methods is
component did mount
and it's a very standard place to put
code that you want run
whenever the component is first put on
the page same kind of thing that we did
with react use effect and
an empty array as the second value
and then we'll go and take the fetch
from the react use effect
it in there
and now we don't have pokemon set again
so we need to use this dot set state
in this case we'll set the value of
pokemon to that incoming data
and there you have it looks pretty good
it's exactly the same thing as we had as
a function component but now you can see
what a class component looks like to
make that a little cleaner i'm just
going to set the variable name to
pokemon
and what that does is when you put that
into
an es6 object like this it
sets the key name pokemon to the data
value
no pokemon just a nice little shorthand
all right so that's all it takes to turn
a functional component into a class
based component
if that's what you want to do but at
least it should give you some
familiarity
with what class-based components are in
react when you see them
in probably what is an older code base
all right so there you go class
components
really quickly welcome back to the
introduction to react series
number 10. i'm jack harrington at jahr
on twitter
and this is blue collar coder so in
previous videos we've used
use state to manage state in our
application our application component
app
and now we want to do is actually
refactor app
into a bunch of different components
which is going to make it more
maintainable
and then we want to share that state
which is in-app
with those components now the first
thing way that we're going to do that is
we're going to use what's called
prop drilling we're actually just going
to send the state
and the state to setters down to those
components using properties
and then we're going to use context it's
built into the react system
and it allows you to go and share state
with components in different locations
without actually sending it to them via
props
all right let's go jump into the code
okay
so we're gonna start with this project
that actually is
the code for the intro to react
number eight because number nine we went
into classes but
don't wanna deal with that in this case
so we're just gonna go back to eight and
start from there and it's linked to in
the description
so over in the terminal i'm going to use
mpxd git
with that url and then point it at
introduction to react 10.
i'm going to change directory into that
and bring up vs code
now bring up the terminal and yarn to
install everything
and now yarn start to bring it up
and it looks pretty good we can filter
and get more info great
so let's go have a look at app.js
and right away we're going to take this
pokemon type so let's copy everything
from prop types
down to the end of pokemon type create a
new file called pokemon type.js
and paste that in there then remove
the unused imports and the css
and then export the pokemon type prop
type
and now back over an app.js let's go
import that
and then remove pokemon type
next thing to do is get this pokemon row
out of here so let's copy and paste that
i'm going to grab everything from button
down
and i'm going to create a new folder
called components
and then within that pokemonrow.jsx
now it's not js it's jsx because
it's got a component in it that's kind
of a convention
really you could use dot js that's fine
too kind of
also depends on your project sometimes
you use js sometimes you
use jsx i'm going to use that jsx so
paste that in there
and then import react
now we don't need css baseline or the
css
and we need to get the pokemon type from
the parent directory
now let's export that as the default
and then back over to app.js let's
import that
from the components directory
and then remove the original
now we can get rid of prop types and
button so we don't need those anymore
all right looks like we don't have prop
types back the original file so let's go
back over to pokemon row
and import prop types
and looks good now let's grab out
pokemon info
and create a new file called
pokemoninfo.jsx
then paste that in there then let's
remove pokemon row we don't need that
and import react and then finally let's
export that
and then go back over to app.js and
import pokemon info
and remove the original
and i forgot to go and do the parent
directory on pokemon type so let's go
fix that
okay looking good so now i want to pull
out the filter
as well as the table so i'm going to
grab out the input
copy that and then create a new file
called pokemon filter.jsx
first thing i'm going to do is define
pokemon filter
as a function
and then paste in what i copied the
input
and then export that and then import
react
so this is looking pretty good so far
but we need filter and we need filter
set so we're going to get those we're
going to get those as props and that's
the first
argument to this function and what we
normally do in that case
is use curly braces and that's going to
open up a destructuring
and then type in what we want so in this
case we want filter
and filter set
and that's good enough so let's go back
over and import that in app.js
and we also need the import for styled
because we want to bring in that styled
input
so let's paste in that style input
and then let's go down and change out
input for pokemon filter and remove the
type equals text
and now we're going to set filter as a
prop to filter
and filter set as a prop to filter set
and remove the original input
and that looks great everything's
working fine
so now let's go and do a similar sort of
thing for that table let's go grab the
contents of the table
create new file called pokemontable.jsx
and create a new function called pokemon
table
with no arguments yet and then paste in
that code
and then again open the destructuring
and we'll
list out what we need here so we need
pokemon
we need filter and we need this selected
pokemon set
now i'm gonna import react
and export this
so now let's go back into that.js and
import pokemon table
copy and paste pokemon filter replace
that with pokemon table
change out filter set to pokemon
and add in the selected pokemon set
last thing we need to do is import
pokemon row
and that looks good
so what's happening here is what's
called prop drilling
so we've got these six items filter
filter set pokemon pokemon set selected
pokemon select pokemon set
and we are passing them to these
components
via properties and there's two problems
with this
one if you prop drill a bunch if you've
got a bunch of layers between
you between this app component and
the target component that needs it and
the components in between
aren't actually using those properties
then that's a problem
and the second problem is that in this
case app
knows a lot about the implementation of
pokemon filter and pokemon table because
it understands
the props that it needs to pass down so
we can't really
change out the implementation pokemon
filter or pokemon table
without changing these props so we're
going to do instead is create
context and use context to pass
these six values to any component that
might want them
so the first thing i'm going to do is
create a new file called pokemon
context.js
and then import react
so i'm going to create a new constant
called pokemon context
and use react.create context to create
it
now react.createcontext takes a default
value i'm just going to use an empty
object
and let's export that
and then we'll import that over in
app.js
and now down in the jsx code
we're going to use pokemon context dot
provider and that's going to provide
that context to
any components in the tree from this
level down
so we need to wrap the whole thing in
this provider
and then we need to set the value that
we want to provide
so we give it a value prop
and then within that an object and then
we give it all of those values filter
filter set all of that stuff
set set set great
so let's go over to pokemon filter
and now i'm going to change it so that
it's not just returning
the component that it's actually going
to have an implementation so i'm going
to turn that into curly brace
and return and then i'm going to take
out the props
for filter and filter set
and then add those as a const
and then use use context
which is automatically added by vs code
that's pretty cool and then give it the
pokemon context
because you can actually have multiple
contexts running simultaneously
so you need to know which context you're
actually interested in
so bring in pokemon context
and now we go back over to app.js
and remove the properties
and now i can keep typing and it looks
great so that's actually getting
filter and filter set not through
properties but through
that context that we created and you can
do that anywhere in the react tree
so let's use the same thing for pokemon
table again we'll turn it into
a regular function
and then grab out the pokemon filter and
select a pokemon set
use context and again automatically
added
give it pokemon context which in this
case it automatically imports how nice
is that
and everything works great how cool is
that
so one more thing we can do is we can
tweak pokemon info
and not use that selected pokemon
and now we're going to grab out the
props but in this case we're going to do
something a little bit different
we're going to start by destructuring
selected pokemon
and then add on those props and the
reason i'm doing that is because
in the original code we'd spread
selected pokemon into the props
of this component so in this case now we
have that select the pokemon object
again and we need to kind of do that
spread
right here so again we use use context
and again we'll put in pokemon context
everything's auto importing
it looks good
but i first want to remove those props
and it still looks good that's great but
now i also want to remove that
selected pokemon check because i think
pokemon info should just stand alone
and should do the check on its own
let's remove the check and now it's
telling us i can't read
the property name no but that's because
selected pokemon
is by default null so let's go back in
and add the check
into pokemon info the first thing i'm
going to do is
remove that cool destructuring because
we need to actually look at selected
pokemon
and i'm going to use then select a
pokemon as a ternary
in the return by using a question mark
operator
and the result is either going to be if
we have a selected pokemon then we get
our react tree otherwise we get null
null as a perfectly valid
return from a react component
and now i've got to kind of re-add that
destructuring so i'm going to add
selected pokemon
and then dot name.english
and select the pokemon.base
and there you go looking super good
super clean code
all thanks to context okay well i hope
you enjoyed that i hope you learned a
lot about used context
and how to use it what we're going to do
next is learn about use reducer which is
going to be a nice
segue into us learning redux welcome to
introduction to react episode 11.
i'm jack carrington at jahr on twitter
and this is blue collar coder
so in the previous video we migrated the
application
to using use context to share state
between the application component and a
lot of the nested components
but we still have three different state
hooks and three different pieces of
state can we congeal those
into one piece of state and one dispatch
system that allows you to go and tweak
that state and send actions to a
thing called a reducer which manages
that state well yes we can it turns out
it's built
into re react it's called use reducer
let's go try it out in the code right
now picking up where we left off we've
got the three
use dates and the pokemon
context.provider
that provides those out to the different
components
first thing we're going to do is create
a reducer
call that pokemon reducer
a reducer is a function it takes a state
and an action
the state is the current state of the
store it's got the
pokemon the filter and the selected
pokemon
then the action is an object and that
object defines the mutation
that's to be applied to the state
and then a new state is to be returned
so in most cases we use a switch
statement
and then we switch on the type inside of
the action object
and that type is a string in the first
case we'll use
set filter
this is going to be an action that tells
the reducer pokemon reducer
to take the current state and then set
the filter key to whatever the payload
is
so we're going to return a new object
it's going to contain all of state
and then we're going to update filter to
the payload
next we'll copy that and paste it three
times
one for set pokemon which is going to
set the pokemon array
and one for set selected pokemon
so first change out the strings set
pokemon
set selected pokemon and
the keys pokemon and selected pokemon
and the last thing to do is set a
default case
in the case of ease reducer you throw an
exception if you don't know what the
action is
in redux you actually just return the
original state so there's a bit of a
difference there
so this is actually a really simple
reducer our app was really simple so
that makes sense
but in most cases a single action is
going to mutate multiple parts of the
state
simultaneously in this case
we are using use reducer simply because
it allows us to get around having
three use dates we can just have the one
use reducer so let's go do that
so we're gonna define a constant array
of state and dispatch
and that's going to be the result of
react.use reducer
and then we give it the pokemon reducer
and then the initial state
so that's an object pokemon set to an
empty array
filter set to an empty string
and selected pokemon set to null
now i'm going to leave the use dates in
here so we have a functional application
as we migrate to the reducer
next thing to do is go and add that to
our context provider we're just going to
go in and add state and dispatch
and let's start the migration by first
looking at our use effect
and now instead of pokemon set we are
going to
dispatch an action to the store
using that dispatch command dispatch
takes an object that object is the
action object that gets sent to the
reducer
so in this case we want the type to be
set pokemon
and we want the payload to be the data
that we got back from the fetch request
the next thing to do is look at this
conditional where it says pokemon we're
going to look at state.pokemon
because that's now managed by the
reducer
so let's take a look okay turns out our
pokemon table
can't find pokemon so let's go
fix that let's go over to pokemon table
and so now we're getting from use
context pokemon filter and selected
pokemon set
so we need to fix that we need to get
pokemon and filter from state
and we're going to use dispatch for
selected pokemon set
so we'll destructure state to get
pokemon and filter
and we'll also get dispatch
so now the code should work because
pokemon is now
set in state and filter is set in state
as well
now we just need to change out that
selected pokemon set for a dispatch
so we'll give it an object again this
time of type
set selected pokemon
with the payload of the pokemon
all right it looks pretty good things
are moving along
but we can't filter so let's go over to
pokemon filter
and do essentially the same thing we're
going to destructure state
and get filter
and then change filter set to dispatch
once again we'll send an object in
dispatch of type
set filter with the payload of the
target value
now in all honesty you can structure
that action any way you want but by
convention people tend to use
type and payload
okay let's try some filtering again and
it looks good
nice but the more information button
doesn't work
so let's click on pokemon info
again we'll destructure state
and now that works too
going back to app.js we can now remove
the use dates
and also remove those from the provider
and there you have it now we've gone
from use state
to use reducer and that used reducer
uses this pokemon reducer function that
pokemon reducer function takes
two arguments state and action and it
mutates
the state depending on what you send in
for that action
and this is really handy to go and
reduce the number of use states the
number of hooks that you
use and it's also really good if you've
got interactions between
parts of the state this is essentially a
model
so it can be as complex or as easy as
you like
and even better is a nice side effect
you can independently unit test this
obviously if you just look at the code
right there's nothing react specific
in there it's just a big switch
statement so it's pretty easy to write a
set of unit tests around it
that test every part of the reducer and
make sure that it's working properly
all right i know that reducers can seem
like an alien concept you've got this
initial state and then you send these
actions into it and those mutate that
state and it's a little weird
but it is the kind of core foundation to
a system called
redux which is very popular and
out there in the wild so if you're in
your career you're probably going to end
up
working on a redux application at some
point and it's worth knowing how those
work
welcome to episode 12 of the
introduction to react series i'm jack
harrington
at jahr on twitter and this is blue
collar coder
so in the previous video we used
something built
in to react called use reducer and
that is actually really close to a
system called
redux which is a state manager that's
very popular
in the react community and so what we're
going to do in this episode is we're
going to port
our existing react use reducer
application
to a redux application so you can see
how that works
all right let's go jump into the code
okay where we left it off was that we
used use reducer instead of use state so
now we're using use reducer in
combination with use context
but there's an interesting history here
the use reducer hook
actually came in after a system called
redux
got really popular and so we're going to
do in this video is we're going to
actually
port our use reducer to redux
and see how that looks so the first
thing we need to do is
add redux and react redux
redux itself is a generic framework
for managing state
in order to connect it to a react app we
use the react redux package that has a
provider
and some handy hooks that allow you to
easily
pass your store around and then
dispatch to it and get the state
let's start it up again
obviously still working
so the first thing we need to do is
change our react reducer to one that's
compatible
with redux and the only difference is
that you return the state
as default in a redux reducer
we're also going to set the initial
state up here
pokemon as nfd array filter is an empty
string
and and select a pokemon as null
next we need to import create store from
redux
and provider from react redux
so let's go build our store
say const store equals create store
and then give it our reducer
pretty easy so now we have our our store
and now we're going to take out the
pokemon context rider
and instead of just changing out our
pokemon context provider with the
redex provider we're actually going to
go and change out the default export
and the reason for that is that the app
component itself
is going to need the store so it can't
both
need and provide the store so let's go
change out
the default to a function
and then wrap it in a provider
with the store
looks good so now we need to import
use selector and use dispatch
and these are two helper hooks for redux
apps
so we're going to remove the use reducer
and then get the dispatch from use
dispatch
and get pokemon from use selector
and use selector takes a function that
takes state
and then returns whatever you want off
of it so in this case state.pokemon
so let's tweak that conditional
and now in the react use effect that
dispatch remains the same
which is very nice actually
we can get rid of the pokemon context
import don't need that
and then delete that file
next let's go and fix pokemon table so
we'll remove the context
and then go grab the use dispatch and
use selector from
app.js
we needed pokemon so we got that so
let's go and add one more for filter
so copy and paste that and then change
out filter
now remove the use context
and the last thing we need to do is do
the import let's go grab that
bring it in and we don't need the
provider
okay so now pokemon table is ported
let's head on over to pokemon filter
paste in the code
all we need is filters so we can just
remove that
remove the context and then remove the
use context
and then the context import
and then bring in the import
all right looking good next thing to do
is
tweak pokemon info
this time we need selected pokemon
and we're just removing the context
and then remove everything we don't need
and finally do the import
okay really good really clean
and now it works that's awesome so we've
successfully sported an
app from use reducer
to redux in just a few minutes
so redux is a lot to take in and i
totally understand that
so there are great videos and resources
on
egghead and other places on youtube that
you can go to
really dig into redux i will say that
redux
is a kind of falling out of favor but
there's so many applications
that are using redux that it's worth
understanding how that works
all right episode 13 of the introduction
to react series
i'm jack harrington at jakur on twitter
and this
is blue collar coder so in the previous
videos we've learned a lot about
use state use context user reducer and
now
redux but there's a lot of new state
managers coming out and i wanted to show
you one that i'm actually really excited
about and it's called
zustin it's a weird name but it makes
state management between parts of your
reactory
super easy so
let's go jump into the code so we have a
redux app and we want to try something
new
we want to try a state manager called
zustand
so let's take a look down here this is
the way that we create the store in
zustin
we gotta bring in zustin as a package so
in this case
it's managing a number of bears and the
bearish starts at zero
and then it's got a method on there
increased population
which is a function that function then
calls that
set that we got in the beginning that
set takes another function
which takes a state and returns the new
state
based on whatever that is going to do
and so in this case increased population
increases by one and remove all removes
all the bearers from the population
which is very sad
and the result of that is a new hook
so we're creating a custom hook for
ourselves which is really cool
and that custom hook is called use store
so let's go and try this out
first thing to do is remove redux and
redux react don't need those anymore
and then we're going to add zustand
let's start that up and obviously boom
so the next thing to do is create a file
called store.js and it just paste in
that code that we got
then we'll export that
of course we're not doing anything with
bears so let's change out bears
to pokemon make it a empty array and
then set filter and slide to pokemon
and now we need three setters so we've
got set pokemon
now it's gonna take pokemon as an
argument and that's fine you can have as
many arguments in there as you want
then that function that goes to set is
going to return the current state
plus the pokemon that it got as an
argument
so that's pretty clean now i just need
that for
except filter and set selected pokemon
okay and that is our zustin store
all right let's go back over to app.js
and start porting this over
first you need to remove the redux stuff
now we're redux free in our app.js
and let's bring in use store from store
and then down an app we're going to say
cons pokemon equals use store
and use store takes a function it gets
given a state
and then it selects out what it wants so
in this case we want state.pokemon
and we also want set pokemon
so that's really nice you actually get
your setters the same way that you do
your state
so now instead of dispatch we can just
call set pokemon again
so set pokemon takes a list of pokemon
and then sets that in the states
so now we can replace that entire
dispatch with just the set pokemon
let's jump on over to pokemon table
import that
paste in our you store code
so we need pokemon copy and paste that
replace it with filter
we also need set selected pokemon so
let's change set pokemon to set select
the pokemon since we need that
then remove the redux stuff
and import use store
and then finally change out that
dispatch for the set selected pokemon
okay this is looking good this is
looking very zustindy
let's copy and paste these top two lines
paste that into
pokemon filter and we'll change out
pokemon for set filter
and then remove the redux stuff
bring in use store
and that looks good last one to fix is
pokemon info
all we need is selected pokemon paste
that in there
and they'll bring in you store
oh and we missed one dispatch where do
we miss that i see okay so over in
pokemon filter restart was dispatch
let's fix that
and there you go there's our zustan app
and all that you need is this one little
store
all right so we can make this even a
little cleaner
let's go back over into our app and then
take the fetch
and put it over in store.js
and in this case we don't have set
pokemon
so we're going to turn that back into a
function i'm going to say that we get
our list of pokemon
and then use use store.setstate
in turn takes a state and just like
before we return the existing state
and then pokemon
and then we can remove all this code
from app
and that's even more clean
now the store manages its own initial
fetch for that data which is great
and finally we can remove the use store
from the app
and there you have it redux to zustant
in just a few minutes
in that cool you go and essentially
create a new react hook on the fly
that you then share data around with i
think that's really
really cool and powerful and i hope you
enjoyed learning about zustand
and want to dig in further well
introduction to react
number 14 i'm jack harrington at jahr
on twitter and this is blue collar coder
now in the
previous episodes we have done state
management with
redux with you state with
zustand and now we're going to look at
one more estate manager and that's
an old friend of mine mob x it's been
around for a long time it has a
different take
on how to do state management i like it
a lot i'm interested to see if you will
like it as well
so let's go and import our pokemon
application
to mobx okay so here's our existing
pokemon search amp
and we can filter on stuff we can get
more information
so we're going to use mobx instead of
what we have right now which is zustand
and let's scroll down here to a quick
example so here you've got a timer is a
class
and the magic sauce is in the
constructor where you do this make
auto observable and then give it this
which is a reference to itself
and so that's going to take every field
and make it observable
in this class and by observable that
means that when it changes
whatever is observing it will also get
updated and then to create the store you
just
instantiate a new one of those objects
then over on the react
side you use this observer in mobx react
and you wrap your components in that and
that makes them update whenever
any field on the store that they
observe changes let's firebar terminal
then go into introduction to react
bring up vs code let's start it up just
to make sure everything's fine
and looks good
okay so the first thing i'm going to do
is remove zustend
and then add mob x and mobx react
okay let's start up again and we expect
a crash here
and we get that no zustin is found
surely not
so let's get rid of the zustin and then
import from
mob x
that make auto observable
that we'll use inside of our class so
let's create a class for store
you don't have to name it store you can
name it whatever you want we've just
gotten into the habit in the web world
calling everything
a store i don't know why that is so
let's first make our fields a pokemon
filter and select a pokemon by copying
and pasting those in
and then fixing those up
and then we'll create the constructor
that's going to call that make auto
observable
just like from the documentation and now
we just need to create some setters
so let's create a set pokemon
it takes a pokemon and then sets
the value to that and then do the same
thing for filter and selected pokemon
now we can get rid of the store and to
create a new one we just create a
constant of store
and then create a new store
and we'll return that store now the
fetch that's kind of interesting so what
do we do with that
well all we need to do is just call set
pokemon
on the store
and give it the pokemon
it's really that easy now head down here
and just fix up use store at the bottom
okay now i've got to go change out the
components now this is a real drag
you can't imagine how hard this is going
to be so let's go find anywhere we use
that store looks like in app.js we don't
use a store at all
let's go here to pokemon filter okay we
got a store right there so let's change
our use store to store
let's import that observer from mobx
react
and then wrap the pokemon filter
function in that observer
now here you go ready for this how tough
this is check this out
so we're gonna have to change out filter
to store.filter
and we're gonna have to change out this
handler to say store.set filter
and now we can remove the zest and stuff
and
that's it that's all we need to do so a
quick second before we go on to the next
file
what we're doing here is we're basically
saying that the value of this text field
is going to be stored up filter
and then whenever we get a change value
we're going to go take that event and
call the set filter function on store
so what observer is doing in this case
is watching that component
and whenever it requests the value of
any observable it's saying
great this component is now subscribed
to
in this case store.filter and so
whenever store.filter changes
this component gets updated and that's
it
as a as clear as it gets all right so
let's tidy this up a little bit
nice to be succinct and we'll go on to
the next file
pokemon info also uses stores so let's
paste in observer
change use store to store
wrap the component in the observer
and then just change selected pokemon to
store it outside to pokemon
and that's really it let's go on to the
next one pokemon row
it doesn't use a store so we don't have
anything to change there
let's try out pokemon table it does have
a store so let's bring in that observer
change use store to store and then
add store where appropriate
and then remove the zustin stuff and
finally wrap the pokemon table in the
observer
and now let's head over to our site and
it's
working wow okay
let's try it out apparently it filters
well
i can do more information and it works
okay well
either it hasn't reloaded which is maybe
the case
or it's real let's try this out so i'm
gonna stop it and then restart it
you know just to make sure that like
we're not seeing a cached thing
i mean that that was pretty spot-on oh
wow okay
all right then it actually is working so
do we have any issues let's go over
the console okay so it looks like we
have some issues around keys and prop
types so let's fix those
because this probably existed before i'm
guessing
so let's go into pokemon row i see okay
we have a key here where we don't need
it and then we go back into pokemon
table and then add that key where it
should be
okay that's fixed that key problem
and then we have a prop type problem
here
so we're looking for an array of pokemon
types as opposed to just a pokemon so
let's get rid of that
and then get rid of the prop types don't
need that
okay one more thing apparently pokemon
id is mistyped
let's go over to the pokemon type ah id
is a number
that is true thank you react and we're
clean
okay so we've not only migrated to mobx
but we've actually done some
housekeeping that's great
obviously we've just touched on the bare
surface of what modbx can give us
one thing that i wanted to look at in
particular is computed values
so let's go over here and have a look at
computeds
and what you can do is you can say that
certain fields are computed
meaning that for example in this case
right the value of total is actually
just computed from
an observable field called price times
another observable field called amount
so let's try this out i'm going to go
and
grab this section of this example
bring it over into our store
and now we no longer have make auto
observable so we need to go and specify
which fields are observable and which
fields
are computed
so in this case pokemon filter and
selected pokemon are all observables
and then we're gonna have a new field
called filtered pokemon which is
computed
so the way that we implement that is to
create a getter
with filtered pokemon as the function
and let's head over to the pokemon table
and get the implementation for this
so we're going to take this filter
section here
and copy it and then paste it into
filter pokemon here
and replace store dot with this dot
okay so now we've got a computed value
which has pokemon but
filtered by that filter string and now
whenever pokemon or filter change
then filtered pokemon will automatically
update
so let's go back over to our pokemon
table
and just change out stored up pokemon to
stored up filter pokemon
let's go take a look at that worked
and it works great awesome
so why did we do that well what we've
done is we've moved the business logic
of the filtering from the
visual component back into the
model or store or whatever you want to
call it
so that creates a nice separation of
concerns right you've got the
store that holds the mechanics of the
app
the fields and any kind of business
logic
and then you've got the view which
basically just takes whatever that is
and puts it on the screen so that's one
of the things i really
like about mobx is that ability to just
define a class
as a model and then just use it kind of
almost as
is i mean if you now go over and take a
look at that story.js file
right it is very clean you have one
class
the only concession that you have to
make to mobx
is that make observable in the
constructor and that's not a big
concession
all right i hope you can see why people
like mob x so much it's a very
clean system that at least for me kind
of hues to my mental model of how estate
management is done
if you have any welcome to introduction
to react number 15
i'm jack harrington on twitter and this
is blue collar coder
so in the previous videos we've been
looking at state management we're going
to shift gears
and we're going to look at react
frameworks and in particular
next js so we're going to port our
pokemon application
to nexjs which is a very popular
framework so why do we want to do that
well next.js is a critical job skill in
the react marketplace so i want you to
have that and understand how it works
but i also want us to look at the three
different deployment methodologies
that next js supports and that'll be
client side rendering which is what
we've been doing
so far there's server side rendering or
ssr which we'll cover in the next video
and then there's static site generation
or ssg
which we'll cover in the video that
follows
but to start all that we gotta port our
application to next js so let's get
after it
right now okay so here's what we've got
today
and this is in create react app it's our
pokemon search
we've all seen this before so we're
going to move it over to nxjs
very popular react framework so we're
currently in introduction to react so
let's bring up that because we're going
to need to copy some files across and go
back up a directory
and do mpx create next app
which is going to create a next js app
for us
and then give it introduction to react
dash next js
and let's let that chew for a bit
now let's bring up vs code
then we'll start the application and in
this case we will do
yarn dev which is essentially the same
as yarn start
just means start the application but in
development mode and there you go
there's your next js
boilerplate so we want to get all of our
code from
here into there so the first thing we
need to do is copy across some files so
i'm also going to use the finder here
so open that directory now here is the
next.js app with its pages we'll get
there in a bit
but for the moment i want to go and
create a new directory called components
and then copy across our components from
the original app
next i'll create a new directory called
source and that's going to have the
store
as well as the pokemon type so let's
bring across those
now source and components you don't
necessarily need to call those
directories that i have worked on a
couple of next js apps and they
do generally have business logic type
stuff
in a source directory and then shareable
components
in a components directory the only
specially blessed
directory is that pages directory
okay so back in vs code it looks like
those directories are there now
so over in pages we have index.js and
that's basically your landing page
so there's a ton of boilerplate in here
we're just going to remove all that
we don't need head anymore
go over to app.js and start copying in
some stuff
we'll bring in the imports
pesos up at the top then bring in our
style
divs paste those in there
and they'll bring in our app layout
and paste that in there
now these imports are wrong since the
components is now in a pure directory so
let's go and just add an additional dot
okay so a bunch more things to fix here
but first off let's go and add in all of
our
libraries that we don't have so we'll
add in mobx
mob x react emotion style
emotion core material ui core
and i think that should do it let's take
a look around yeah it looks
looks to be about that okay
so let's go change our imports first you
gotta fix up store
that's now in the source directory same
thing here
same thing here
thing here okay looks pretty good
one more thing is we need our pokemon
json so let's go copy and paste that
out of the original project
and we're going to go and create a new
file in public called pokemon.json
and public is just the static assets for
this project
so this json file is going to be hosted
as a static asset
all right let's start it up on yarndev
and so right away we run into something
with
next.js when it comes to server-side
rendering versus
client-side rendering so what's
happening here is that
next.js is trying to render that
home page on the server and the home
page is bringing in components those
components rely on the mobx store
the mobx store has some code in it that
does
that initial fetch to go grab the
pokemon json file
what's happening is that it does the
fetch here
has the wrong url now we could put on
there
http localhost 3000 slash pokemon json
which would be
accurate and would allow for server-side
rendering in this case but
i just want to go and execute this on
the client only so i'm going to take out
that starting react
and then i'm going to say if the type of
window
is not undefined
then fetch and this is a really simple
client-side check what it's saying is if
there's a global called
window and it's not undefined then that
means that we're on the client
so now we can server side render
properly
and it runs how cool is that
so after going and changing all that
stuff now we've got our first
next.js client-side rendered app how
cool
is that okay so let's close a few files
out here
and i'm going to do a little fix up and
remove react from these files
you don't need to put in react that's a
thing in xjs it does that for you
automatically
and now let's go back into pokemon row
and i'm gonna create a link to a pokemon
detail page so we're gonna create a page
for every single pokemon that you can
link to so let's bring in a link from
next
link and
what link does is it provides
client-side
linking functionality so it basically
gives you a a spa
of a sort it'll create a link with an
href
that points to slash pokemon
and then the id and then within that
an anchor tag
and within that anchor tag we'll give it
the english name
now why do you need to put an anchor tag
in there i don't know got me on that one
all right so now we've got little purple
highlights and blue highlights saying
we've got links on here
obviously i've clicked on some of these
before but when i click on them
now it gives us a 404 because it doesn't
know how to resolve
slash pokemon slash 2 in this case
so the way that we handle that is under
pages we create a new directory
called pokemon and then within that
we create a new file called bracket id
dot js
and what this is saying is when you see
pokemon
slash one then map one
to a query parameter called id
and invoke this page so we'll just drop
a simple export in here
hello there
and now we no longer get a 404 we get
our hello there
so let's go back over to index and bring
in some stuff we'll bring in css
baseline
we'll bring in styled
bring in a page container
and now we'll wrap the thing in a page
container as well as bring in the css
baseline
let's have a look all right
now it's a little prettier so how do we
know
what we got in terms of that id well
that's handled by the router
so we're gonna look for with router
and import that from next
and then we're going to wrap this
component with with router
and that's going to give our component a
new property called
router and router is where we can find
our query parameters so in this case
router.query.id
let's take a look and it says there
hello
hello there five and that maps to slash
pokemon slash five which is
the url okay let's bring in our store
and then change this into a function
that returns something
okay whoops our import was wrong so
let's fix that
okay now it's compiling successfully and
we have a store yay
okay so we'll get the pokemon by doing a
find on the store
and we'll get the id
and then we'll find based on that query
id
at that point we'll say if we have a
pokemon
then we'll put up the name pokemon.name
excellent and squirtle if you want it
that's fine
blastoise great so now let's do a little
bit more
just to make this more interesting we'll
start a table
which is defined by material ui core
then define a header
and a row
and within that a cell
for the attribute and then the value
and we're just going to go and iterate
through all the base to go and create
this table so
let's take a look all right we've got
our header that looks good
so now let's create a body
then and then get the keys
for the base
and then map through those keys
and then with every key we're going to
create a row with that key
and then we'll define a key based on key
put in the key for the table cell
and then put in the value from pokemon
base
nice looking table i like it now all
that table stuff comes from material ui
core and gives you that nice look and
there you go
not only have we ported our original
application
to next js we've also now made it a
multi-page application
by creating a different set of routes
and we'll see as the next two videos
show that we'll get more and more
efficient
as to how we build out those pages all
right all right well i hope you enjoyed
that last look
at next js it's a really fantastic
framework and there's so
much more to react so much more to dig
into with your newly found
react skills of course there are things
that you should also
invest in like typescript and we cover
that in detail
on my channel which is linked to in the
description down below so be sure to
jump on over there
and see all kinds of cool videos on
basic and advanced topics
i'll see you there